today we have some really exciting news
about Deadpool 3 it's already really
exciting getting a third Deadpool movie
but even more exciting when you consider
the fact that he's going to be in the
MCU how's it going everybody it's Warren
and this is something that we have all
been waiting for Deadpool to be in the
MCU Deadpool to be able to be in an
Avengers movie and interact with all of
the other heroes and lately we are
getting a lot of news about the 3rd
Deadpool movie that is going to take
place officially now in the MCU real
quick reminder to subscribe to my
channel for your chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and so you can stay up to
date on the MCU so there has just been a
ton of great news about Deadpool this
week earlier this week Ryan Reynolds
posted a picture of himself outside of
Marvel Studios confirming that he was at
Marvel Studios meeting most likely with
Kevin Feige the president and now chief
creative officer of Marvel Studios and
then not too long after we got that news
the writers of Deadpool came out and
said that Marvel is going to let
Deadpool remain rated R and that's big
news for a lot of people on its own a
lot of people did not want Deadpool to
be brought down to a pg-13 rating so
it's good news he's going to be
remaining rated R except for of course
when he comes in movies like The
Avengers or if he came into Spider Man
of course he would be brought down to
pg-13 then and although we have all this
great exciting news Ryan Reynolds is
meeting with Marvel Studios it has never
been confirmed that Deadpool is actually
going to take place in the MCU it's just
been widely speculated but today the
writers have officially confirmed that
Deadpool will indeed take place in the
MCU in an interview with comicbook.com
they said one of the great things about
the MCU is how rich and broad it is for
instance just think about the world of
villains how great the world the
villains are we're never able to use a
lot of those villains because they were
on the MCU well now we can so right away
we're definitely excited about getting
the shot to do that I think Ryan is - I
think the MCU people are - just the idea
of throwing Deadpool into the mix is
exciting to them so there you have it
right from the directors themselves
Deadpool is confirmed to be coming to
the MCU and then to top it all off today
a few inside sources have said that
Deadpool 3 is now in development and
could be coming as early
as 2022 now unfortunately this is not
confirmed yet it's just speculation for
now but since we are getting a ton of
information about Deadpool right now and
Deadpool 3 and since Ryan Reynolds just
met with Marvel Studios it makes sense
that Deadpool 3 could have started being
in development so Deadpool 3 finally
coming to the MCU we finally get to see
Deadpool interact with all of our
favorite characters so let me know how
excited you are about this and the
comments down below and let me know
which character you would like to see
Deadpool interact with in the MCU also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm
also starting a giveaway on Twitter and
Instagram soon so don't forget to follow
me on there and as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll fluff